you originally worked with Quentin
Tarantino on Kill Bill Vol 1
what do you remember about that
experience and then how did you take
your prior work relationship with him to
the hateful eight yeah 13 years ago Cuba
is so exciting film for me it's a very
exciting experience shooting or shooting
in China I'm making a set and this main
set is Hauser believes is there for
action action scene and then 13 years
time is so fast and then creating some
time thought about me for next film and
then this time is hit wait I'm so happy
to work with him
do you almost have an unspoken
relationship when it comes to knowing
like what he wants you're certain things
certain details or lack of detail on
something she want details because he
taught me about this time 70 me
widescreen so he needs a detail of the
in the interior The Hobbit ashtray so I
try my best
yeah it was incredibly detailed I
enjoyed seeing all the things so for the
hateful eight did the two of you scout
locations together
you tell you right yes how was that it's
good when we saw the landscape
Quentin Bob and the
everybody happy and satisfied the
perfect landscape so we decided they
said the habitat reappraise yep
and then the interior of the habitat was
that actually in Telluride or was that
Lee in Los Angeles but yeah he needs a
cold situation so we've made a set in
terrorize his so cold in the winter and
then after that we made a set in the Sun
staging Sanders and same set so we've
made a to set same set I understand that
they kept the temperature very low
because you see the bright yes and then
she needs a cold set so in the set
temperature is the same temperature
there right on the census oh wow yeah
that's not appropriate right yeah
how long did you spend scouting
locations with Quentin first time two
three days and then I went to scout many
times for the place and the setting and
some another situation so when you're
first handed a script mm-hmm what's your
process for first of all looking over
the script and then you know thinking
about what production elements you can
really bring to life yeah actually when
I was child I loved western film so I
learn a lot so I know the the world of
Western how to make it but this time is
very special because the Quentin wants a
very complicated situation haberdashery
he hits clear in the script Harbor -
Sheree is not Harbor - wait please
explain about the situation it's very
funny
oh it's very exciting explanation okay
yeah there's a part in this in the
script says Minnie's haberdashery is a
lot of things but the one thing it
wasn't was a haberdashery so that was
you know very specific that Quinton had
written what because it is is it correct
that a haberdashery is actually for hats
most men's suits open suits okay yeah
well also ba but the nuts not the bar
the drugstore is not the drugs to the
restaurant is not best friend however -
RIA is not Howard a straight his
explanation it's very complicated
so it's interesting and then there was
this beautiful bed in the middle of Lang
yeah I made a 8 corner it joined the
same a one room so one it's a lounge
taken DT a bar so it's a pot bed spot
bear stop and one is a bedroom and it's
a kitchen and dining room and the
fireplace and Joe gage table so each
section is another design another look
but the space is one space did you need
idea sorry
did you make a miniaturized versions
yeah oh yeah and and how are you
assembling that like once you saw maybe
the the locations is that how you didn't
Quentin loves the more they're currently
love to meet your mother and because I I
think Kent
loves the set is it means one of the
character the Minnie's haberdashery
I think the 9th character so he nice
detail for for the character so I made a
history of the Minnie's haberdashery
without minis you understand so you you
kind of envisioned what the history of
it would have been yes that's right
interesting and what are you using to
make these miniatures or you or they're
already pre-made and you're just putting
them into place yeah yeah I I want to
show you something yeah oh wow oh look
at this
yes thank you okay this is my first
drawing this is my first drawing and you
drew this yeah and then acquitting
choose this one I made a few another
kind of design right and oh my gosh this
is a next sketch and this is a set and
this is a model it's your mother
it's interesting this is the Quinton's
drawing right this is my drawing hi drew
so just to prime is starting point so
I'm assuming Quinton drew that first and
then yeah and then I drew this one then
finally this is the final drawing yeah
it's like Oh print yeah Ohan drawing
this time because a Quentin loves the
analog and handmade ah okay yes so no we
at the apartment know they still owe
hunt and drawing and do you have an art
background in terms of drawing and
actual were you trained it was a yeah at
first ID I drew and then image about the
straighter to another step they - Wow
what do you love most about your job my
job what do you love most
hmm thinking and the imagination and
thinking about the first first first
imagination first image when I think how
to say you know like a cool fake icon
idea to get you a dozen take it up so -
when I - initially capture the the world
that's presented in the script those
initial stages of giving birth to that
world that's on a page and is that is
that sort of once you get the directors
notes and you read the script is that
where a lot of your aha moments happen
where you really yeah I don't love for
many movies so from my head many sayings
I thought I found that many cents and
then I found a new image from the many
many movies history what were some of
the biggest challenges with building the
haberdashery in Telluride like whether
it was the outside or what because I
know they were expecting the weather to
be much colder than it actually was
but what were some of the challenges and
how did you work through them because we
have to make set before the snowing so
after constructions snow snow came and
then cover the snow so we don't have
enough time before snowing so it's very
challenging but the is that correct and
then the weather was much milder than
then previously expected what's that
right yeah first it was colder around
November or so and the stuff have to
start shooting is yeah once yeah yeah
once shooting started so with the
haberdashery did that structure actually
exist and you embellished it the Hat the
haberdashery building - ultimate Oh No
kashtanka sugar yeah it was from scratch
yeah okay yeah because it looked like a
lot of vacant land so it sounds like
there wasn't where there was there
resources like running water and
electricity nearby dinky music oh God
mitochondria Martine a mnemonic usually
scare them off Sweeney sweet my game
took off Sweeney are you on about the
scale man I have a feeling there's
nothing no water no electricity no work
so you're bringing in generators and
yet water Wow yeah interesting and the
outhouse that was the house burn uh-huh
Wow and the well and how long did it
take to actually build the entire place
in Telluride from the outhouse that
haberdashery the barn we decide the
place September and the static
instruction may be from October so we
have only two months right okay
what size crew is working with you what
size crews yeah how many people from 30
to 40 oh okay yeah construction
construction oh yeah and then once the
structures built how many people are
actually working with you assembling
little details of the hammering this
this means a set decorator and set
dresser yes after the construction they
come said the question Department maybe
10 to 15 okay yeah so when you were
initially thinking of locations did
Quentin have it in his mind that
Telluride or somewhere in Colorado was
where you would all shoot dirty diner in
the situation in the script this is the
Wyoming yep so we went to Utah and then
Tara right we compare the two location
what's the first step in finding
locations I mean are there I guess
there's I know for LA there's websites
where people put their house all the
time or you can shoot but in terms of
finding like a vacant land like that
where would you start looking no but I
don't know I wish I saw you do it
overall you know okay no I mean we put
I've been a boy and I know by show
humidity gun when he Creole would you go
yeah location so - but she made him I
mean cell location scouting right right
where do you begin
yet director and the same at Glover and
I and produces Stan and think and look
for something and then yeah right and so
you initially wanted Utah maybe you
don't know yeah yes those a message
about a session meeting dinner
so what they called a star called up the
accumulations to creating new yeah over
in Utah you simulated and imagine what
are they have it actually would look
like in that location
yeah look to call Colorado and then
Clinton she murder that game when you're
building a world because the the
haberdashery was so detailed yeah and
and how obsessive are you and and maybe
perfectionistic with little details you
when you see something that you know
what I need to move that do kind of
obsess over something very small come on
guy talk over me to sue any kind of got
the swing she psycho dodo so in kite I
don't know in Moscow I don't check out
some tiny kite I wanted I had to get all
I know dictator no painting budget any
kind of it
I wasn't that that obsessive over actual
small objects but when it came to the
color and how everything was being
painted it's very very specific but set
decorator los Mary's very professional
so a detailed the package and oh yeah
that's not no problem I think and do you
do this for every film you have your own
portfolio of ideas what sample something
like that every detail mm-hmm it's print
so texture yeah texture and Compaq its
Wow muted colors very muted okay okay
lastly any advice for someone wanting to
get into production design what would
you tell them let's say there's someone
graduating college right now or maybe
they don't have college experience
production design and disasters do you
know otherwise study Moscow they learn
the classical film they should see that
out of him yeah sure like any
suggestions certain directors I learn
from creating a lot so Quentin loves
always film I love both film to so first
step is I'm from out the film any anyone
in particular who's your favorite
creators a lot gone with the wind
no is required this time this time I
love Shane when I was child I saw the
sharing in the movie theater in Japan
this is the
my first very good memory
okay yeah so